what is wrong it's fine
I'm gonna die alone you're never going
to meet someone wearing cargo shorts
they're functional I've got my wallet
and keys I can't beer which you'll thank
me for later oh wait for me
pregame or booty call hi there dinner
culture waffle thank you I'll have a
steak and I'll start with the tuna
tartar hungry aren't you oh yeah make
minimum wage at the diner down the
street would you like to get out of here
okay
great way to have my lights on this
month what nothing all right kill me and
how was last night it was fine I made
pancakes yeah and did you have these
pancakes last night or this morning hey
Jim it's good to see you you gotta be
kidding me
they're way too many weddings and I'm
freaking out seven weddings in the year
it's gonna be false just make your
speech funny sad and then make it cute
and then hopeful okay how do you think
will screw up this wedding I don't think
we're already doing it
tell us all about your family date my
mom and dad divorced we do not live
branches up in this family tree we just
wait for them to dry up and fall off hmm
I'm here with my boyfriend and his ex
who is that damn she's trying to steal
your heart and I'm gonna stop her by
dancing
[Music]
are you sure you don't want any water
you seem really drunk
[Music]
you
you